le téléphone avec vues partout
la dernière évolution dans ce domaine
mais attention les prix sont encore
chers compter quinze mille francs et
surtout ajouter 3 francs par
communication et par minute
pour le moment seuls 160 in français
possèdent un téléphone portatif ou de
voitures inventé aux états unis le
téléphone à ses débuts et méprisés et
puis par la suite
lentement il va conquérir le monde par
le câble pour commencer et grâce au
satellite
ensuite il va devenir l'ami le confident
de millions d'habitants sur la planète
on dit ou téléphone ou parce que tous on
l'appelle aussi parfois que deux
absolument votre voiture
oui elle bull à champigny c'est un
accident trouver quoi est ouverte et ont
roulé par une voiture par une voiture la
personne nous appelle a besoin de nous
donc il faut que ce soit très rapide et
nous avons mis des moyens modernes
téléphonique pour que l'on puisse avoir
son adresse très rapidement on ne reste
pas longtemps avec la personne on n'a
pas le temps de discuter il faut que
tout de suite on envoie les moyens donc
ça dure à peu près 30 secondes
combien de vies le téléphone at il sauvé
aucune statistique ne l'a jamais montré
une belle revanche pour cette invention
car sa naissance qui est utilisée que
par certains et qui a
rousseau